you also have to accept the bad parts
that go with it you can accept the bad
parts you have to you can't you can't
just have the good without the bad
what's the worst thing that happened you
had an actress the worst thing I mean of
rejection or whatever I mean I mean
getting killed off Dexter was pretty bad
I had no idea I had no idea that was
coming when did they tell you um three
days before
who called you um they called me in on
my day off to do some ADR and then they
called me to the producers room and I
knew walking from the ADR stage to the
producers room when you get called to
the producers you're being killed off a
show I mean it's just you just yeah I
suffer from panic attacks and I started
having a panic attack and I called my
manager at the time and I said oh my god
I think they're killing me off and he
that says what he said he's like all
right kid okay because you know he knows
I suffer from panic attacks and he's
like just get in now as fast as you can
just say thank you and get out and I was
like okay and then I called my husband
he was my boyfriend at that time and I
said and he's not in the business and I
said oh my god I'm walking to the
producers office I think I'm being
killed off the show and he's like maybe
they're giving you a raise which like
really broke my heart because I was like
no way he's gonna fight for the raise
and then he said the same thing and he
said just get in and out as fast as you
can and get home and I'll meet you at
home
so I tried to get it out as fast as I
could like I walked in the room and I
said you know I know what this is about
I wanted people it was three the three
executive producers all men know one
woman yeah and I said thank you so much
for a great four years I've appreciated
every mother I did for the world before
they said what I said I'm smart enough
to know what's going on so thank you for
great four years let's talk tomorrow I
mean because I'm feeling the panic
attack they wanted to you know to have a
conversation and so then I had to sit
down
and you know it's wait let me release at
this stage because to make matters worse
I worked out a gym right by the studio
and so I was I had worked out that
morning and it was really hot like hot
like today hot so I was only in a sports
bra in a pair of like leggings and I
went to do a - I hired you I went to do
ADR that way so all I could think about
was what was that movie where the guy
gets broken up with while he's naked
is it forgetting forgetting sarah
marshall forgetting sarah marshall
that's all I could think about was like
I don't have a shirt on and I'm losing
my job and I'm like sitting there like
trying I think I felt so vulnerable but
they wanted to discuss it they wanted to
tell me the reasons why and and in I you
know they needed to do that for their
own their own clarity I guess their own
therapy because everybody was upset
about it but you cry in the room I did
which I didn't want to that they hug you
they did but I was sweaty and smelly the
clothes on basically were bawling I was
I was really upset you loved the show I
loved it oh it was such a great family
and then here you are being told like
okay well we're still gonna like get
together as a family but you're on your
own so it was really hard
how long did it take you to recover from
that it took a while it took awhile
I am I remember therapy for that I did I
did did they pay for no I should have
they should have I remember I met um
Elizabeth Mitchell right after I was
doing I got I was doing some little
indie film and I was working with her
and the episode hadn't aired yet so
nobody really knew and I was talking to
her and set one day and I I told her
about it and you know she had been
killed off of lost and it was a very
similar situation where like they didn't
tell you they don't you know didn't tell
the actor until the last minute they did
tell her - last minute or whatever and I
was like you know they want me to do
press for the show and do interviews
after it airs like how do I handle that
and she's like just be honest
where does what I did was like yeah I
got killed off the show it's the hooked
for me like I was upset you know she's